jadis à hareville les moulins de
Brasseuil étaient à haut et si la
rivière est imuable les moulins eu ont
évolué mais dans cette profession
exercée de père en fils la tradition
demeure malgré la modernisation
précurseur de la filière bio depuis 1972
c'est le seul site des Yvelines à
posséder un moulin à Meulle en pierre
clind on revient vers le côté nature qui
a été un petit peu décrié un peu chahuté
dans les années précédentes et qui a
aujourd'hui prend son prend sa vraie
existence son son sa vraie valeur en
ayant des produits naturels des produits
tracés des produits de la région ce en
quoi nous on croit depuis des années à
aujourd'hui ben on est content que ça se
en Île-de-France on on revoit cette
cette force et c'est une vraie force des
moulin de Brass exemple d'engrais et de
produits chimiques les farines bio
conservent toute leur qualité
nutritionnelle blé sègle épautre et
petite épautre inlassablement les farine
sont écrasé broyé et renvoyé d'un bout à
l'autre des
conduits contrôle qualité vérification
suivie des dossiers le métier de meunier
aussi s'est adapté au temps
moderne je dirais que le métier il a un
petit peu évoluer parce que en tant que
Responsable de Production avant c'est
essentiellement être beaucoup beaucoup
sur le terrain alors que ça l' toujours
mais parallèlement il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de travail en amont lié à la
qualité au matériel à la maintenance
donc c'est beaucoup plus complet je
pense qu'avant c'était il y a il y a ça
plusieurs années en arrière c'était
surtout beaucoup plus technique le bio
exige de la transparence et une
traçabilité les échanges avec les
laboratoires pour analyser les qualités
des produits son leségion une exigence
qui engendre un chiffre d'affaires de 3
millions 450000 € en évolution malgré la
crise car la part du bio augmente
d'année en année une offre qui répond à
une demande croissante en 2011 les
moulins de Brasseuil ont produit 5258
tonnes de
farine